public health pseudo experts and their
political allies are unmasked as science
deniers
the andrew brown case comes apart and
the radical left's mask comes off when
it comes to winking and anti-semitism
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment i have a lot of news to catch up
on
with you we'll get to that in just one
moment first let me remind you you are
spending way
too much money on your cell phone bill
well you know there are certain things
that are inevitable in life like death
and taxes well
there's a third thing that is inevitable
if you are getting your cell phone
coverage from one of the big providers
that means that you are spending too
much money instead you should switch
over to pure talk usa right now puretalk
saves the average family of for over 800
a year which is a lot of money
here is the best part you don't have to
sacrifice coverage because it's on the
exact same network as one of those big
providers
friends switching is easy you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids
right now you can get unlimited talk
techs and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month
and if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for it it's just
one of many reasons they've been named
the top wireless provider
by consumer affairs from your cell phone
and dial pound 250
say ben shapiro you will save 50 off
your very first month of coverage that
is pound two five zero
say ben shapiro to get started again
i'll pound 250 say my name ben shapiro
you will say 50
off your very first month and you're
gonna be saving hundreds of bucks down
the road because you're not going to be
spending too much money
on one of the big cell phone providers
instead check out puretalk usa limited
talk tech six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month and if you go over on the
data they're not going to charge you for
it go check them out right now dial
pound 250
say ben shapiro to get started alrighty
so
over the past few days it appears that
the biden administration
has now come around to the science and
many in the bible administration are now
acknowledging
that they were lying about the science
for months on end some of us were saying
from the very early days of the pandemic
that once you had had covet you were
basically immune now to covert and
you're not passing covet and that is
what the statistics showed
some of us were also saying that the
masking was really only necessary in
close quarters
and once you are vaccinated you are done
once you are vaccinated and two weeks
past that second vaccination
you are done and you'll recall that on
friday because joe biden had a very bad
news week he decided that he was going
to unmask
publicly well now anthony fauci the
greatest of all doctors except for dr
joe biden who
as we all know is the greatest doctor in
the history not only of america but of
the world it goes like dr joe biden
hippocrates dr anthony fauci dr j
dr pepper and then all the rest of the
doctors dr
fauci yesterday he admitted on national
tv
that he was wearing a mask for no reason
which is weird because when he was
sitting
in front of the senate and rand paul was
questioning him about this he was like
no there's a very good reason it's the
variance
except there wasn't and voucher was
lying when your public health experts
acknowledge that they have lied to you
now
about a variety of issues for your own
benefit maybe you should stop listening
to them and start looking at the
underlying data here is fauci
acknowledging that he's a liar
i'm obviously careful because i mean i'm
a physician and a healthcare provider i
am now much more
comfortable in in people seeing me
indoors
without a mask i mean before the cdc
made the
recommendation change i didn't want to
look like i was giving mixed signals
but being a fully vaccinated person the
chances of my
getting infected in an indoor setting is
extremely low
and that's the reason why in indoor
settings now i feel comfortable about
not wearing a mask because i'm fully man
i'm fully vaccinated so in other words
he was fully vaccinated months ago fauci
is an elderly dude he was obviously at
the top of the healthcare chain
that dude was vaccinated months and
months and months ago probably as of
january
at a minimum okay and and dr fauci was
walking around for months on
end indoors with a mask when he was
asked about it he said well it might be
necessary why
because he wanted to mirror the
political predilections of the biden
administration again it is just a source
of astonishment to me
that we have treated the trump
administration for a year on kovid
as a great controlling force standing
above the public health establishment
and bossing them around and telling them
what to do and twisting the science
and here you have anthony fauci openly
acknowledging that he lied to you for
months
because he wanted to send you a message
that it was important to mask even after
you were vaccinated and only once the
vaunted cdc decided to get on board did
he decide to unmask
well rand paul had something to say
about this he said well um
weird because i was saying this to you
before and then i'd get trended on
twitter every five minutes
for saying that you were wrong well rand
paul was right and fouchy was wrong
every exchange they've had for the past
several months rand paul was right and
fouchy was wrong
my question to him would be did you just
discover vaccine immunology
did you not believe in vaccine
immunology a couple of weeks ago when i
asked you this
or were you doing it for show and it
sounds like you heard him say
he didn't want people to see him without
a mask
the thing is the science hasn't changed
we've known that
when you're vaccinated we've known this
for quite a while that you're not
transmitting it and not getting it we've
known that
for months now but also vaccine
immunology if you believe in it if you
believe in the vaccine
that's what happens you don't have to
wear a mask afterwards so the masks are
coming off
not just obviously physically but they
are coming off in terms of politics
right now democrats are continuing to
maintain their adherence to masking
even when it is completely unnecessary
there was a bizarre situation yesterday
in which a bunch of republicans unmasked
on the house floor
and this included people like marjory
taylor green but it also included thomas
massey and a bunch of other house
members and jamie raskin of maryland who
was vaccinated
came over and started yelling at them
and saying why are you unmasking
and the answer is they aren't masking
because why in the world would they be
masking at this point
there's no reason for them to if
everybody in the chamber has had the
ability to get a vaccine which they have
once you're vaccinated you don't have to
care whether somebody else is vaccinated
or not
and if you wish not to vaccinate and you
wish to be in a public setting you also
that's that's your responsibility you
want to give it to each other that one's
on you
and if you're vaccinated you shouldn't
care again nancy pelosi has maintained
these house rules that say
that you have to mask on the house floor
for no reason at all
in fact the current house rule states
that masks must be worn in the chamber
except when speaking during debate the
members can go without masks in house
office buildings and elsewhere in the
capitol complex
rule breakers are fined 500 bucks for a
first offense and 2 500
for a second offense brian mass
republican of florida
led this rebellion the army veteran
interrupted a republican conference
meeting to tell his colleagues he was
done wearing masks and would not wear
them on the house floor going forward
last week mass rose during a house vote
and asked that given the updated cdc
guidance we all take off these stupid
masks
mas said i'm not going to play her
stupid game in this pelosi it falls
somewhere between dog and pony shows
smoke and mirrors and pure manipulation
and apparently the the other members who
refused to ask included chip roy of
texas lauren pobert of colorado thomas
massey of kentucky
beth van dyne of of texas gary stoube of
florida and mary miller of illinois
pelosi says that 75 of the house members
are fully vaccinated she says we can't
go back to pre-pandemic operations with
of the people vaccinated and the other
25 having had the opportunity
to get vaccinated okay so what this is
at this point it is just pure politics
and when it's unmasked it's just pure
politics what that means is that it was
always
pure politics when you take off the
phantom of the opera's mask and
something ugly is underneath the thing
that was ugly underneath was always
there it was just being masked
okay this has been this has been pure
politics for a year at this point
over a year i mean we're in may for over
a year this has just been pure politics
and the media continue to promote
the pure politics because they continue
to suggest that you need to continue
masking up
why well because how can you trust the
guy next to you again if you're
vaccinated you don't have to trust the
guy next to you that's the point of
a vaccine but the media continue to
promulgate this nonsense
why because if they can continue to
prolong the feeling that the pandemic
is a real problem in american life and
that it is uh something for biden to
overcome
and it gives him something to push
against and it tends to
jog the the american public into wanting
things from the government as opposed to
going back to regular life we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that there is
a service
for you if you have a bunch of stuff in
your garage that's just moldering out
there and i'm not talking about like
boxing i'm talking about like your films
i'm talking about film reels i'm talking
about photos right these are
irreplaceable memories and they're out
there in your garage just falling apart
you need to get them preserved
right now with legacy box legacy box is
an ingenious mail and service to have
all those irreplaceable moments trapped
on videotapes camcorder tapes film reels
and pictures
converted to dvd or digital right now
they are offering 50
off plus free shipping on orders over
100 bucks exclusive for our listeners
let me tell you it's a great service i
did it for my parents they had a bunch
of film reels from when they were kids
converted over to digital format
they've been able to watch it for the
first time in decades the process from
start to finish is super simple you pack
and you send a legacy box their team
digitizes everything by hand
and then you enjoy you can get back
perfectly preserved digital copies on
thumb drive dvd or the cloud
ready to watch and share they even
provide state-of-the-art tracking and
send you updates at every step of the
process
i know the people who founded it nick
and adam they are awesome dudes they're
truly honorable go check them out right
now get started preserving your past
today
go to legacybox.com shapiro to get an
incredible 50
off plus free shipping on your order
over 100 bucks buy today take advantage
of this exclusive offer send it in when
you're ready go to legacybox.com
shapiro save 50 plus free shipping while
supplies last
offer only valid until may 28th go check
it out right now legacybox.com slash
repair to save
50 plus free shipping already so
the new york times has a piece today
called the new honor system on masks
am i to trust these people when tory
sailor 27 stepped out of her apartment
in kalamazoo michigan last week
she knew that the center for disease
control and prevention had already given
fully vaccinated americans the go-ahead
to shed masks in most situations
miss sailor who is vaccinated wore one
anyway and when she summons an elevator
in her apartment building she confronted
her first real test of the new era
twice the doors opened to reveal people
who were not wearing masks and twice
she let the elevator go am i to trust
these people having never met them
said miss sailor who has multiple
sclerosis and gets an infusion therapy
that compromises her immune system
despite her vaccination status it is
unclear whether her body will be able to
effectively produce antibodies to fight
off covet 19.
okay but that's going to be true forever
i mean and literally for most diseases
like if you are immuno suppressed
there's a different story for you but
the vast majority of people who are
addicted to the mass are not
immuno-suppressed
the vast majority of people who continue
to wear the mask are people like nancy
pelosi
who's okay right these people are doing
it as a form of virtue signaling it is a
way
of spotting the people in the crowd who
are like you and they are the good
people the good people wear masks even
after they're vaccinated to demonstrate
just how wonderful they are the new york
times says our capacity to trust other
people's honesty has already been tested
and fibs or omissions may have happened
along the way did every person who drove
across the state line follow 14-day
quarantine rules
did everyone who got an early vaccine
fit the eligibility rules at the time
so it's no surprise that the latest
honor code the federal government's
guidance encouraging vaccinated
americans to take off their masks
was greeted with skepticism in parts of
the country that have not already done
so
fewer than half of americans over the
age of 18 are fully vaccinated well
first of all a much larger percentage
are at least half vaccinated which gives
you a large amount of immunity
it's a very complicated symphony right
now said dr howard markle a
medical historian at the university of
michigan there's been such an erosion of
trust distrust for government distrust
for the virus just trust for this party
or that party so when you tell the
public what to do there are people who
say how can i trust the guy
without the mask okay but again nobody
is saying
that people who are unvaccinated have
lost all risk now that they've decided
to unmask all we are saying is that once
you've had the opportunity to get
vaccinated if you've turned it down that
one's on you
immunosuppressed people are a different
story as i've said all along then you
take whatever precautions you have to
take just like you would with any other
serious
illness if you're immunosuppressed or
you have some sort of medical issue
but the vast majority of people right
now who are continuing to wear the mask
are people in blue cities who have
decided they are better people for
wearing the masks even after vaccinated
or people who have a screw loose
because so much of this has become
cultural and so little of it seems to be
about science
okay the mask is coming off with regards
to the teachers unions too so randy
weingarten the head of the american
federation of teachers she admitted
yesterday that the
cdc had indeed sought her advice on how
to write their school guidance
with regard to reopening which is insane
right that's crazy that's the interest
group
writing the rules for the road and
parents are beginning to
have it with the american federation of
teachers they are done she was on
washington journal on c-span
and people just called in and just
slammed randy weingarten as they should
here's the thing for the left as the
masks come off the situation gets worse
for them not better
the true left is not a spectacle that
you like to see
the left has to hide behind joe biden
and his barely animate visage the left
has to hide
behind the media pretending that what
they are doing is guided by science and
moderation
when people get to see the left full in
front of them they don't like it very
much
randy weingarten is one of the people
who represents the hardcore radical left
and people aren't liking it there was
one parent calling in to slam weingarten
i mean no disrespect to you but you know
this union thing one time in our country
a union was a wonderful thing
now the union creates lazy ineffective
people
and it also creates children that have
no education
i look at my grandchildren it is
pathetic how the teachers union
and the government has failed our
children
i don't see how you could sit up there
and defend that
you can see how weingarten is very
unhappy with with this particular
caller and then and then a teacher
called in and slammed weingarten and
said i'm confused why are we shut right
now
unfortunately you started off by
throwing the last administration under
the bus
uh but you know that was kind of just
one thing that happened
that's all right the part that i don't
understand is how come the
parochial schools and the private
schools
could navigate their way through this
scenario
but the public schools didn't seem to be
able to
manage that yep americans are very
unhappy
they are very unhappy with with the
entire direction that the left is taking
them
because the entire mandate for joe biden
was to be not donald trump and instead
he took it as a mandate to be as radical
as he wanted to be to please his teacher
union allies
to have anthony fauci out there lying on
behalf of the administration for
political purposes
when the masks come off people don't
like it we'll get to
racial issues in just a moment because
the masks are coming off on racial
issues as well it's pretty astonishing
how fast the masks are coming off
honestly we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about how you
can keep yourself and your family safe
and secure so it's not just a matter of
owning the weaponry to protect yourself
it's also
god forbid somebody breaks into your
house you want to actually be able to
protect your body right this is why you
need
ar 500 armor while the news tells us
that 5 million people became first-time
gun owners in 2020 it doesn't tell you
many people invested in body armor as
well
people all over the country are buying
body armor from ar-500 armor to protect
themselves and their families
at levels never seen before the second
amendment protects both arms and armor
body armor is purely defensive some
armor is so discreet nobody even knows
that you have it
so whether you want armor for discreet
use in public or something more robust
for protection while you're hunting or
at the shooting range our friends at ar
500 armor
have you covered air 500 armor has
multiple packages built for responsible
citizens
people just like you looking for varying
levels of protection they make the
shopping process simple and approachable
their team
is always willing to help answer any
questions you might have and best of all
they've put together some packages
specifically for listeners of the daily
wire so there's something for everyone
at ar 500
armor.com i know the people who run it
these are people who share your values
and my values as well go to ar500
armor.com
ben see all their promotions and special
packages running right now you can use
codeben for 20
off anything else in their entire store
plan right now for how to protect
yourself and your family for the future
get yourself the body armor we trust
from ar 500 armor at ar
500 armor dot com slash ben visit air
500 armor dot com slash man
use code better check for 20 off okay
so meanwhile on racial issues the left
radicalism is is being unmasked
pretty routinely this is pretty
astonishing today
mayor lori lightfoot the mayor of
chicago apparently
she has now announced she will only be
giving interviews to black and brown
reporters
and this is just racist i mean i'm sorry
it's just racist if joe biden were to
say i'm only giving interviews
to white catholics everybody would say
that is
racist and that is discrimination lori
lightfoot says i will only give
interviews to people who look like me
and the entire left just kind of shrugs
that's the way that it goes
first of all it may violate
constitutional provisions she is a
government officer discriminating openly
on the basis of race
nbc 5 chicago political reporter mary
ann ahern took to twitter on tuesday's
state quote as chicago mayor reaches her
two-year midway point as mayor
her spokeswoman says lightfoot is
granting one-on-one interviews only
to black or brown journalists apparently
the same message was given to wttw
chicago tonight anchor and correspondent
parachute who tweeted i was told the
same thing
chicago politics reporter heather sharon
also tweeted i can confirm
okay that is probably a violation of the
law but the fact that this is even
considered a possible political strategy
demonstrates how insane
the left has become lori lightfoot is
considered a mainstream democrat
and yet this sort of thing is tolerated
not only tolerated but celebrated
on the left meanwhile false narratives
are trotted out on a regular basis and
then
when they fall apart you just never hear
about it again so here's a perfect
example
you may have heard because we talked
about on the show about this case of
andrew brown jr right so andrew brown jr
was shot his 42 year old black man
and he was shot to death as he drove his
vehicle last month in elizabeth city
north carolina and you'll remember there
were there were big there's talk of
riots there was a big protest that was
held
the family did a big presser and they
had people like benjamin crump there
and there they accused the officers in
this case of pure murder
here is benjamin crump who can be found
at
every shooting of a black person by a
police officer justified or not he is
found there explaining that it is
actually just dead straight murder here
is benjamin crump
explaining that this was murder and then
it turns out not too much
attorney harry daniels will put this in
greater context
exactly execution
execution
the streets don't get done okay so you
can hear people shouting that this was
murder and that the cops need to be
arrested
and benjamin crump got up there and he
said the exact same thing well now it
turns out that the body cam footage has
been
released so yesterday they released the
body cam footage what happened here is
that andrew brown
was a drug dealer okay and they were
there to deliver a drug warrant this all
a ledge right the ledge drug dealer they
were there to deliver
a drug warrant and andrew brown decided
to try and run down cops with his car
so here is what the body cam footage
looked like
so you can see the cops they're hopping
out the guy's in his car he starts to
back up
and then and they're telling him to stop
they're telling him to stop
and then he tries to drive over some of
the cops when they shoot at him
right that's that's what happens okay so
when people say that he was unarmed a
car is a deadly weapon right if you run
over somebody with your car that is
considered assault with a deadly weapon
he andrew brown backs up once the once
the
swat team arrives to deliver the warrant
and then he proceeds to try and drive
forward
through the cops which is why the d.a
came out and said
no there's not going to be a prosecution
pasco 10 county district attorney andrew
wamble said during its news conference
on tuesday that they were justified in
their actions the cops because they had
reason to believe they were in danger
andrew brown jr was fatally struck by
gunshots on april 21st according to the
washington post
as he attempted to drive away from
deputies who were executing a search
warrant on felony drug charges at his
home
womble who previously said the shooting
was justified held the news conference
to discuss details of the state's bureau
of investigation findings
womble said brown's attemptedly
escalated the situation from show of
force to employment of force
during the news conference womble
recounted the events of april 21st brown
was sitting in his dark bmw on the day
officers from multiple agencies
attempted to search to serve
search and arrest warrants based on
alleged drug activity at around 8 23 a.m
a detective drove his vehicle in front
of browns to prevent any forward
movement
two deputies approached brown's car on
the driver's side as two others moved
toward the passenger side with guns
drawn as they gave commands to brown
brown threw down his phone as officers
approached closer and quickly backed his
car away from officers
as one had his hand on brown's driver
door handle
that deputy was pulled over the hood of
the car according to womble when brown
backed up enough to the point where he
was blocked by his home
he turned his steering wheel to the left
toward the law enforcement officers
who were scrambling to get out of the
way and yelling for him to stop
according to womble and the video
footage
the first shot was fired during this
moment piercing the front windshield of
brown's car as his vehicle continued to
move
more shots followed hitting brown's
passenger window and rear passenger side
door
while his vehicle continued to
accelerate across a vacant lot toward a
white van occupied by an investigator
officers fire
fired five additional shots i mean total
time as you can see from the video
is five seconds okay so there are
eyewitness statements that suggested
that it was much longer that these
officers basically were waiting and then
they just shot him for no reason at all
but that is not true okay it happens to
be that in all likelihood he was trying
to conceal evidence and then he was
trying to run over cops brown had
abrasions on his body that were caused
by the shrapnel apparently
and a plastic bag in his mouth with a
substance that's consistent with crystal
meth
although autopsy and toxicology reports
haven't been finalized according
to the d.a the footage shared by one
will brought more questions by reporters
at the news conference who pressed him
about saying brown was aiming for
officers instead of fleeing
the clips have also prompted more
criticism about how authorities handled
sharing information
with the public and of course you have
people saying that the footage was
cherry picked
okay um cherry pick that's the video
that's the video
and here's that we've now reached the
point in american life where even the
unmasking of a story is untrue
doesn't actually change the story that
is told by the media it just brings
further questions right when there is
video of jacob blake
holding a knife and resisting a rest and
reaching into his car
and there being a knife on the
floorboards of the car then we are told
that the cops still shouldn't have shot
him when there is full-on video
of a 16 year old girl attempting to stab
to death another 16 year old girl
while shouting that she's going to kill
her that is still not enough for people
remember that time
it was so cute when americans were naive
enough to believe that body cam footage
was actually going to answer a lot of
these questions
and then it turns out that people don't
give a damn about body cam footage
because the narrative is all that
matters
but here's the thing i think for most
americans the narrative is not all that
matters
when it comes to most americans they
believe what they see with their eyes
and the narratives that are being
promulgated by the media and by the
democratic party
are just they're just not true now there
have been narratives promulgated by the
right that are not true
that happens too but as the masks come
off
the people in power are being unmasked
as people who are willing to twist
fact in order to achieve a political end
and you can see that in everything from
coveted policy to race policy
you can see it with regard to what's
going on currently in the gaza strip
with regard to israel
and hamas okay so the latest
on the situation in the gaza strip we'll
get to that in just
one moment first let's talk about the
fact that there's really no great reason
to go to the post office post office is
a wonderful place they can do a lot of
great services for you
but why wouldn't you just do all of that
from home and get discounts while you do
it
thanks to stamps.com you don't have to
go to the post office anymore you can
mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer you can send letters
ship packages and pay less a lot less
with discounted rates from usps
ups and more stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups directly to your computer it's a
must-have for any business whether
you're a small office sending invoices
or a side hustle etsy shop shipping out
orders or you're just navigating the
hybrid
work life stamps.com handles it all with
ease you can simply use your computer
and print official us postage 24 7 for
pretty much anything with stamps.com you
get discounts up to 40
off post office rates up to 66 off ups
shipping rates stamps.com it's a
no-brainer we've been using it since
here at daily wire i use it personally
there's no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com promo code shapirostamps.com
never go
to the post office again alrighty so the
latest on the situation
over in the gaza strip is that israel
continues to bomb hamas hamas continues
to fire
flurries of rockets at civilian areas in
israel and
as with every time israel fights back
against the terrorist group hamas or
against fatah which is a terrorist group
or against islamic jihad which is a
terrorist group
if it goes on for more than a couple of
days then the world's like no this has
to stop
this has to stop and it doesn't matter
that israel as a sovereign state
not only has the right people use this
phrase right to defend yourself right to
defend yourself is like the most basic
of human rights but
it's not about israel just has the right
to defend itself israel has a duty to
defend its citizens
end of story israel has a duty to kill
the people who are firing rockets at it
they have a duty to stop and neutralize
the threat of having to put
tens of thousands of citizens
underground every day for weeks on end
that is their duty the united states
government has the same duty to you
okay any government has a duty to its
citizens to prevent them from being
targeted by terrorist groups and the
fact that this is even remotely
controversial is beyond me it's it's
crazy to me that people see this as
controversial
or that people see some sort of moral
equivalence here you have to be out of
your moral mind
in order to believe this truly now the
way the new york times and the media are
playing this of course is
again it's about the narrative and that
narrative is being unmasked every single
day
right the way that they treat this is
completely free of context so what they
will say is
well man israel has hit a lot of the
sewage systems in gaza
i mean they've knocked out a
desalination plant okay israel is
attempting
to kill people who are firing rockets of
their civilians those
terrorists deliberately hide among
civilians they deliberately hide
in areas with high value targets
to the to the palestinian people the
palestinians don't want their
desalination plan said
hamas is hiding their rockets next to
the desalination plans
hamas is hiding the difference between
israel
and its enemies is that israel uses its
rockets to defend its citizens
hamas uses its citizens to defend its
rockets
and hamas is interested in using human
shields in order to prevent israel
from knocking out its weaponry which is
why they build these tunnels under
civilian areas it is why they fire
rockets from civilian areas we've shown
you that video before
there is not only no moral equivalence
here there is no geopolitical rationale
by which what hamas is doing is
justified in any way whatsoever
even their purported rationale with
regard to sheikh zarah this idea that
israel
having a 50-year ongoing court case that
that ends
with the eviction of four buildings in
sheikh zarah
if you think that's an excuse to fire
hundreds of rockets into civilian areas
by the way killing israeli arabs
killing foreign workers in israel you're
out of your mind you're crazy
even on a legal level the whole thing is
crazy the fact is sheikh shara is
largely arab
not every arab in chichira is being
removed the only buildings that are
being
cleared and evicted are buildings that
have been under legal dispute there are
a bunch of buildings that between 48 and
67 the jordanian
government which had grabbed that land
as part of the 48 war
handed legal title to the buildings two
arabs who were in that area
those legal titles have been upheld by
the israeli courts okay so
this is the whole thing is wild the idea
that what happened on al-aqsa
had anything to do with jewish
interventionism is insane on its face
al-aqsa is off limits to jews okay it is
because it was being used as a staging
ground for riots specifically because
again
this whole thing was started by mahmoud
abbas fatah party mahmoud abbas canceled
elections at the end of april and then
because he canceled elections because he
thought hamas was going to win
he decided he was going to launch a
round of violence and hamas not wanting
to be one-upped by fatah decided to get
involved by firing hundreds of rockets
at israel it is that simple that is that
is what is happening right now because
guess what
israel is not in the gaza strip israel
abandoned the gaza strip in 2005
at great cost okay i know people
who are cleared from the gaza strip i'm
talking about jews jews who had been
there
for years and decades and they were
forced out of their homes
it was jews removing jews so they could
have a true apartheid state in the gaza
strip where there are no jews
and that area is completely run by hamas
and hamas is now firing rockets over its
border
into into israel it's an amazing thing
that anybody sees moral equivalence here
you have to be so ignorant and so stupid
and so morally backward but
fortunately we have a world full of
stupid ignorant and morally backward
people
the new york times is putting all the
focus on the humanitarian cost in gaza
without of course
recognizing the reality which is that
all of the damage that is being done is
being done because of what hamas is
doing
they say the nine-day battle between
hamas militants and the israeli military
has damaged 17 hospitals and clinics in
gaza
wrecked its only coveted test laboratory
sent feted wastewater into its streets
and broke water pipes serving at least
800 000 people
setting off a humanitarian crisis that
is touching nearly every civilian in the
crowded enclave
of about two million people okay number
one israel has been providing free water
and electricity to the gaza strip
for literally decades beyond if israel
wanted to
make life super miserable all they would
do is just cut that stuff up but they
won't do that because israel is a
humanitarian state how humanitarian is
israel
israel reopened a border crossing so
they so israel could send humanitarian
aid into gaza
hamas started firing rockets at the
humanitarian crossing
sewage systems inside gaza have been
destroyed says the new york times a
desalination plant
is offline dozens of schools have been
damaged or closed forcing some 600 000
students to miss classes
at least 213 palestinians have been
killed including dozens of children now
the new york times
doesn't acknowledge where it got those
deaths the answer is it got those stats
from hamas but if you want to know
why children and civilians are dying i
have a video that explains exactly why
children
are dying in the gaza strip okay this is
courtesy of sky
news i believe in the in the arab world
okay and it's been translated so this is
an idf phone call
to a gazan to evacuate his building
with civilians before they were bombing
right we have tons of tape of this
israel does this routinely
if they want if they want to knock out a
piece of military infrastructure because
hamas tends to locate in civilian areas
they will call the buildings
and tell people to clear out which is
certainly not what hamas is doing hamas
has been firing rockets randomly into
israeli cities and hitting whatever they
can hit
cars buildings children they don't care
israel calls first
the the meaning of this conversation and
i'll read you the transcript of the
conversation as it plays out
it just demonstrates the lack of moral
equivalency here okay so here's the idf
phone call they called a gazan
to say evacuate your building we're
gonna bomb the building
[Music]
so i can't get all of the people out i
need at least
israel says no brother we need to do
everything we can so you don't die yeah
uh
and the israeli says god forbid god
forbid what are you doing he says this
is how we reveal your cruelty
i mean i don't know exactly what you
expect of israel are they expected to
not
perform their duty and defend their own
citizens what exactly are they expected
to do
all the people who pretend that they
give a damn about the palestinians by
the way
all these people do not give a damn that
hamas which is an actual overt terrorist
group
funded by iran dedicated to spending
tens of millions of dollars every single
year building terror tunnels to kill
israelis and harm israelis they don't
care that these people are living under
hamas repression
over 40 people were just arrested in
hamas stand in the gaza strip
for supposedly spreading jew propaganda
no one cares about that
because they don't care about the
palestinians all they care about is that
they don't like the israelis this is not
about being pro-palestinian this is
about being anti-jew
that's all this is okay and and the
media will take any
opportunity they can in order to push
this stuff so when i hear joy reid
saying things like americans have no
empathy for palestinians
no you have no empathy for palestinians
so long as you wish for the palestinians
to be governed by hamas
and by the palestinian authority and by
islamic jihad
i mean it's unreal you didn't care about
these people five seconds ago the minute
that they started firing rockets into
israel and israel started defending
itself and its citizens
then all of a sudden your humanitarian
side came out weird weird how that work
joy read
i have to say congresswoman i've been
you know following this from a distance
from a really long time
and i've never felt like americans
really
care that much about palestinians as you
said they don't hear palestinian voices
there seems to be no empathy i mean gaza
is a prison
okay gaza is run by hamas
gaza is run by hamas israel is not
occupying the gaza strip they removed
themselves
15 years ago but jory doesn't know
anything
and she's a moral idiot so that's just
the way this works unfortunately we'll
get some more of this in just one second
because the moral idiots are all over
our media
first let us talk about your sleep
quality so you know
you don't just need a great mattress and
great sheets you need a great pillow
which is why i've recommended my pillow
but now my pillow is doing something new
it's not just about sleep anymore my
pillow is making my slippers the
slippers took over two years to develop
they are designed to wear indoors and
outdoors all day long
my slippers are made with my pillow foam
and impact gel they help prevent fatigue
they are made with quality
leather suede i can tell you firsthand
these are very comfortable you are going
to love them i wear them my wife wears
them as well
every sabbath i slip into my slippers
and they are just great for a limited
time my pillow is offering 40
off they're new my slippers that is 40
off i have sheets and pillows and
slippers from my pillow and like all
their products comfort
is key go to mypillow.com click on the
radio listener square use promo code
daily wire you'll also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets or call 800 951
use promo code
dailywirevisitmypillow.com right now or
call 800-951-7163 that is 800-951-7163
or visit mypillow.com
right now okay so the media continue to
be garbage
at their jobs the right before
the jewish holiday of shavuot which is
why i was off for the past couple of
days
israel knocked out this building in gaza
which was being used by hamas
just clearly being used by hamas okay
and the associated press had offices
there now the reason that hamas locates
in buildings with the associated press
there
is specifically because they wish to use
the associated press as a shield
this is why because then israel hits an
empty building okay there's no one in
there
they hit the empty building and then the
associated press starts whining to the
world about how terrible it is that
israel would knock down a building how
awful awful that israel would do this
sort of thing except
that israel had apparently showed
smoking gun material classified material
to the us government explaining that
hamas was in the building
okay which is not a shock because hamas
and the associated press
have a covert deal that deal is that
associated press gets to stay in
hamastan so long as it prints hamas
propaganda
and does not print stuff that it knows
about how hamas uses civilians as human
shields
david harsanyi has a good piece over at
national review about this
according to ap ceo gary pruitt he said
his organization
had no indication hamas was in the
building or active in the building he
said this is something we actively
checked to the best of our ability
we would never knowingly put our
journalists at risks this is nonsense
says harsani pruitt knowingly puts
journalists at risk every day he sends
them to places like gaza
but how did pruitt actively check did he
ask hamas did he call the landlord did
you ring the bells
it is of course highly probable that
hamas was using journalists as human
shields
because this is what it does during the
last major outbreak of violence in 2014
gaza shifa hospital became a de facto
headquarters for hamas leaders who could
be seen in the hallways and offices
according to the washington post the ap
did not report that
why because they were working hand in
glove with hamas
in 2014 former ap reporter matty
friedman recounted quote the ap staff in
gaza city would witness a rocket launch
right beside their office
endangering reporters and other
civilians nearby and ap would not report
it
not even in ap articles about israeli
claims that hamas was launching rockets
from residential areas
this happened hamas fighters would burst
into the ap's gaza bureau and threaten
the staff
and ap would not report it this also
happened cameraman waiting outside shifa
hospital in gaza would film the arrival
of civilian casualties and then had a
signal from an official turn off their
cameras when wounded and dead fighters
came in helping hamas maintain the
illusion that only civilians were dying
this to happen the information comes
from multiple sources with firsthand
knowledge of these incidents
now what's incredible about this is that
there are members of the obama
administration
who fully acknowledge that this happened
okay there are members of the obama
administration who fully acknowledge
this was probably being used as a hamas
headquarters
okay tommy weeder who worked for barack
obama he didn't just drive his van he
was one of his advisors he tweeted out
yeah probably kamaus was in the building
but that but still you shouldn't hit the
building
unreal because at a certain point it is
not about being pro-palestinian because
if you're pro-palestinian you should not
be pro-hamas
it is about just being anti-the jewish
state and you can sense why okay because
there's a broader left-wing agenda out
there
unfortunately it's what people have
termed accurately the red green alliance
and basically
green being hamas red being communists
there's this long
time feeling on the left that israel is
a colonial state that
israel is an outpost of western
civilization and so many of the people
who are angry at western civilization
are angry at israel they're not angry at
israel and therefore they're angry in
america they're angry in america and
therefore they're angry at israel or
they're angry at europe and therefore
they're angry at israel so europe
because europe has always had issues
with jews has attempted to separate off
except for a couple of countries right
now like hungary and austria
okay but the reality is that the left
all over the western world
has decided that israel is the bad guy
why because israel is part of this
broader rubric
of hierarchical values the way the left
views the world
is that if you are successful in a
civilized system it is because you have
victimized someone
this is the view in the united states in
the united states from the left the view
is
that if you are successful in the united
states it's because you have white
privilege or because the system was
built to accommodate you
or because you have internalized your
own whiteness and
the same thing happens internationally
if there is a group that is successful
and you can castigate them as white jews
suddenly became white for this purpose
and you can castigate them as white
versus the quote unquote brown
palestinians which is the way that
rashida talib talks about this
then that is just another indicator of
hierarchical systems that have to be
torn down which is why you've heard
rashida to leave explicitly say that
she'll say black lives matter is the
same thing
as the palestinians they are not the
same thing for a variety of reasons they
are not the same thing
and for one black lives matter as a
movement last night trex was not
supposed to be firing rockets into
american cities
i was told the black lives matter
movement was distinct from the rioters
and looters if she wants to make a
different claim that's on rashida talib
but it is not a surprise to see black
lives matter supporting hamas they came
out and tweeted yesterday black lives
matter stands in solidarity with
palestinians we are a movement committed
to ending settler colonialism in all
forms and will continue to advocate for
palestinian liberation
always have and always will be free
palestine by free palestine they don't
mean a separate state of palestine
living alongside in peace and harmony in
jewish states they mean wiping out the
state of israel this has been in the blm
manifesto for quite a while
okay faith for black lives is a group
that put out a letter
to the biden administration trying to
urge biden
not to sell weapons to israel to defend
itself
okay and unfortunately this has infused
a huge percentage of the democratic
party
this this whole perspective has infused
a large percentage of the democratic
party
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about a great new
podcast so you've seen people vaping all
the time
it has overwhelmed the young young are
vaping all the time how did that
movement even get started if you don't
know anything about vaping it's a really
interesting sort of business story
wondering's new podcast mini series the
vaping fix is the story of silicon
valley idealism blind ambition and how
the now infamous e-cigarette company
jewel
hooked a new generation on vaping in
2015 the founders of joules set out to
create the ipod of e-cigarettes a
perfectly designed device that would
disrupt the tobacco industry and help
traditional smokers quit
but their fruit flavored vaping options
high levels of nicotine and youthful
influencer endorsements led to
consequences that would put millions at
risk
as plumes of vape clouds surrounded
schools across the nation parents
politicians and the government demanded
answers
was this jules plan all along or did
ambition just blind them from seeing the
pitfalls of their own invention
the podcast is really interesting it's
hosted by laura beale it's from the team
behind dr death in bad batch it's the
vaping fix listen to the vaping fix on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and ad free by starting
your free trial
of wondering plus in the wondery app go
check it out wonder he does
really terrifically produced work go
check out the vaping fix hosted by laura
beale today already in a second we'll
get to the democrats buying into this
broader narrative that israel is part of
the
the coalition of western oppressors
first
there's no better time than right now to
win a free trip to the daily wire
headquarters complete with front row
seats to a live show and meet and greet
with candace owens when you sign up
as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 20 off your new membership
and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios to
see
candace live not only will you be
hanging out with candace you'll be
getting an inside look at her studio our
office
and front row seats to watch her take
down leftist live and in action on her
talk show candace
this is happening right now so don't
sleep on it go enter to win a candidate
vip pass right now at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off and
for an experience that only
joe biden could forget now as i'm sure
you all know
daily wire has been growing like
insanely fast we didn't just move the
whole company across the country we also
released our first feature film
we have a movie deal with giancarano we
launched a new talk show with candace we
have
my show debunked all within the last six
months and we have big plans
we're moving fast so i'm excited for the
future of the company and we want you
involved first of all thank you for
being involved thus far
also we want to continue to include you
in the future plans every day on the
show
i talk a lot about products and services
from sponsors i love
and use but we want to get to know you
better so we can actually tailor our
sponsors
to you so please go to dailywire.com
fill out my audience survey tell us a
little more
about yourself and sweeten that whole
experience those of you who complete the
survey will be entered to win a 1 000
gift card but you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show
so if you want to increase your chances
of winning a thousand bucks go listen to
michael moles andrew claven or matt
walsh to get access to their surveys as
well again
my survey link is dailywire.com shapiro
we would love to hear from you you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so there's a battle going on inside the
democratic party right now and that
battle is
how far do they want to go in pursuit of
the radical left's vision of tearing
down the system
joe biden posed himself as a moderate
then he got into office and he's been
very immoderate okay with regard to
israel so far joe biden has been
kind of shockingly moderate i would have
expected him to cave immediately to the
rashida talibs and the aocs but the
house democrats are moving in that
direction pretty damned fast
house democrats yesterday blocked
consideration of a bill
sanctioning hamas's financial supporters
so hamas is firing rockets at civilian
areas and house democrats are trying to
protect them
according to fox news house democrats
rejected a republican push on tuesday to
consider legislation that would apply
sanctions on hamas militants amid an
escalating military conflict with israel
democrats blocked a bid to bring the
palestinian international terrorism
support prevention act up for
consideration
in a 217-209 vote along party lines the
bill was introduced by representative
brian mast of florida
it would impose sanctions on foreign
entities known to have provided
financial
assistance to hamas among other measures
mass was reintroducing the bill it
passed the house unanimously in 2019
unanimously so all 200 democrats who
voted against this voted in favor of it
when trump was president but now that
biden is president
and now that half the democratic party
has proved that it is
in the pocket of of people who are at
least hamas supporters
they are more than happy to vote down
the ability to vote for a bill that
would cut off financial aid
to hamas an actual terrorist group okay
so this is
it's amazing the entire media will cover
the battle between liz cheney and kevin
mccarthy but nobody in the media
really sees fit to cover the internal
battle happening inside the democratic
party on whether to embrace hamas
or whether to not embrace kamas and that
seems like a major battle because joe
biden is wavering right he's right on
the line so for example joe biden
he has vetoed to his credit resolutions
at the united nations to condemn israel
which is insane first of all the united
nations the garbage organization they
should salt the earth
the building should be knocked down they
should salt the earth it's just a
horrible organization it's a bad idea to
begin it's a bad idea now anyway
biden has done the right thing on that
he's mostly stayed out at this point
which
is the proper thing to do when a united
states ally is facing down a terrorist
group
it's amazing that we have to actually
say these things out loud but biden is
simultaneously
attempting to placate his left wing so
he went and visited michigan yesterday
and he was hanging out with rashida to
leave and decided it would be worthwhile
to kiss this anti-semite ass
rasheed to leave where's rashid
i tell you what rasheed i want to say to
you that uh
i admire your intellect i admire your
passion
and i admire your concern for so many
other people
and it's my from my heart i pray that
your grandmom and family
are well i promise you i'm going to do
everything you see that they are
on the west bank you're a fighter and
god thank you for being a fighter
she's a fighter i mean for hamas it is
worthwhile remembering at this point
that we're shooting to leave upon
entering office
somebody who went to a world map in her
office and put a post-it that said
palestine with an arrow toward israel
on on map so yeah rashida talib is a
radical anti-semite she has been for a
very very long time
and there is the president of the united
states praising her well she confronted
biden on tuesday over his support for
israel
urging him to stop enabling a government
she said was committing crimes against
palestinians according to a democratic
aid familiar with the exchange
during a conversation on a tarmac in
detroit where biden had arrived to visit
a ford factory talib
echoed a scathing speech she delivered
last week on the house floor telling the
president he must do more to protect
palestinian lives and human rights she
of course does not care that hamas
is a terrorist group that is presiding
over the lives of millions of people in
the gaza strip and was about to take
over running
the judea and samaria areas of the west
bank as well
meanwhile you have the the biden
administration
busily pursuing deals with the people
who are enabling hamas so the same time
that biden
is sort of taking a moderate position on
israel
as a broader policy position he is not
as a broader policy position the
administration continues to pursue
some sort of deal with the exact terror
state that is enabling hamas
right now according to the new york
times iran is exporting hundreds of
thousands of barrels of oil each day
violating american sanctions even as
world powers negotiate to lift the
economic penalties
and revitalize a nuclear accord that was
rendered all but defunct by the trump
administration
so now iran is violating the sanctions
they are exporting oil
and the biden administration is trying
to deal with them as they funnel that
money into hamas
it's it's it's not a con consistent or
coherent policy
and i just don't think that biden holds
up against the left flank of his party
for very long here
the biden administration is far too
focused on revitalizing a bad vision of
the middle east in which iran
is a regional power which is why of
course shinseki at the white house
was ripping the trump administration for
what's going on now let's be real about
this
this is happening as a result of the
biden administration deciding to make
nice with iran
and as a result of them deciding to
restore air restore aid
to palestinian terrorist groups but here
is gensake trying to blame trump for
that
i would say that we are not following
the same tactics of the prior
administration
uh we the president has reinstated
humanitarian assistance
uh and security assistance to the
palestinians that's something that was
stopped back in 2018
and we felt was uh not a constructive
action by the prior administration
aside from putting forward a peace
proposal that was dead on arrival
we don't think they did anything
constructive really to bring an end to
the long-standing conflict in the middle
east oh you mean except for
signing actual peace deals between arab
nations and israel sure but here's the
thing
is this administration going to continue
to hold up against its own left lane
i highly doubt it you have members of
the obama administration who freely
acknowledge by the way
that hamas uses ap offices as bases
explicitly fundraising for groups like
islamic relief crooked media put out a
fundraiser for islamic relief
a group that was labeled a a an illegal
organization by the israeli minister of
defense
in 2014 because they were directly
funneling money to hamas
okay so the sort of red green alliance
lives and and it continues to run
it's it's pretty incredible stuff
alrighty we'll be back here today with
an additional hour of content we have a
lot more that we didn't get to here so
make sure that you subscribe so you can
get that in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
where he discusses democrats accusing
pro-lifers of sexism and racism as a new
abortion case heads to the supreme court
you can hear more details about that
story over on michael's show it's
available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowski
editing is by adam sciovitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
democrats accuse pro-lifers of sexism
and racism
as a new abortion case heads to the
supreme court twitter suspends a spanish
politician for observing that men cannot
become pregnant
and dr fauci admits another misdirection
check it out on the michael knowles show